Whether they feature a deal with
the Devil or a two-faced scientist,
these classic horror movies don't
need dialogue to keep you up at night.
"It's the Golem of Prague. Legendary
defender of the Jewish people!"
The concept of the golem has been a popular
part of Jewish folklore for hundreds of years,
and it still endures today. The legend that
has proven to be the most widespread centers
around Judah Loew ben Bezalel, a 16th-century
Rabbi who resided in the city of Prague. Legend
has it that Rabbi Loew created the golem to
protect the Prague ghetto from persecution.
This is the tale presented in the 1920
silent horror film called "The Golem:
How He Came into the World." The film itself was
actually the third in a trilogy, serving as a
prequel for a larger narrative — but the other two
have been lost to time. Sadly, "How He Came into
the World" is the only one of Paul Wegener's
golem stories that you can still watch today.
Just as it's described in the legend, Rabbi Loew,
predicting tragedy for the people of Prague,
looks to craft a way to protect his people. He
sculpts the titular golem out of humble clay,
and gives him life so he can fulfill his
role as a protector. "The Golem" holds
an important place in film history, given
its status as the earliest feature-length
film to feature a man-made monster — over a
decade before "Frankenstein" came out in 1931.
It's impossible to talk about silent horror
cinema without mentioning the German expressionism
movement of the early 1900s. The style — most
prevalent from the 1910s to the 1930s — had
an emphasis on representing feelings more so
than reality. This was often expressed through
painted dreamlike visuals which utilized
heavily distorted shadows and bizarre,
angular shapes. The German expressionist
masterpiece "The Cabinet of Dr. Caligari"
has been hailed by many film historians
as one of the first true horror films.
Our protagonist is Francis, who regales a
stranger with the tale of an ordeal that
he and his fiancée Jane had faced. He
tells the story of how he witnessed a
bizarre public spectacle courtesy of
a mysterious doctor by the name of
Caligari. The sinister doctor presents a gaunt
somnambulist — or sleepwalker — named Cesare,
who can seemingly predict the future
at Caligari's command. It's soon
revealed that Cesare is a murderous monster under
Caligari's control — and Jane is his next target.
Everything in this world, from the
windows to the streets to the shadows,
has a surreal and distorted quality to
it. Despite being over 100 years old,
"The Cabinet of Dr. Caligari" is still an
effectively atmospheric and unsettling watch.
"Now, you all know the plot to 'Jekyll
and Hyde'… but you don't know the story."
Robert Louis Stevenson's 1886 novella "The
Strange Case of Dr. Jekyll and Mr. Hyde" is
often regarded as a seminal work of horror
fiction. Its influence has wormed its way
into countless other works — from comedies
like "Me, Myself, and Irene" to comic books
like "The Incredible Hulk." The story of
Jekyll and his sinister alter ego Hyde has
been put to screen a number of times — but one
of the most famous takes on the iconic story
is the production released in 1920, starring
John Barrymore as the dueling personalities.
While this version isn't a fully accurate
adaptation of the original story,
its terrifying take on Mr. Hyde more than makes
up for it. John Barrymore's portrayal is nothing
short of disturbing, aided by his naturally
expressive face working in tandem with some
mild makeup enhancements. It was so disturbing at
the time that, according to an archived review of
the film in Photoplay Magazine, many were
worried that his performance would prove
unhealthy for expecting mothers. There have been
many other versions of Stevenson's haunting tale
of science gone wrong, but this early silent
version still stands out as one of the finest.
This next selection of silent screams comes from
Sweden in the early 1920s. "The Phantom Carriage,"
directed by Victor Sjöström, is based on the 1912
novel "Thy Soul Shall Bear Witness!" by Selma
Lagerlöf. This eerie experience follows a boozer
named David Holm who, after an ill-timed fight,
dies just as the clock strikes 12 on New
Year's Eve. Now he must accompany Death in
his carriage and collect the souls of the dead
for the following year. David is also shown key
moments from his life — certain key decisions
that he definitely could've made differently.
At its core, "The Phantom Carriage" is a
fantastical morality tale that utilizes
horror elements to convey captivating themes
and ideas. It's no surprise that the film has
been praised for its influence on other classic
movies. If you're looking for haunting visuals
and plenty of lingering questions, definitely
take a ride on "The Phantom Carriage."
"Haxan" is another example of Swedish horror and a
prime example of how early filmmakers would try to
push the envelope. This movie is a bizarre beast,
as it switches between fictional narrative tidbits
and documentary-style segments — both focused on
the "facts" and folklore concerning witchcraft.
The documentary segments are quite
slow and feature a lot of pointing,
but contain some interesting facts regarding
witches and Satan worship. These pair nicely
with the narrative portions, which
feature dramatizations containing
horrific visuals that still hold up today.
These include grotesque looking demons and
even a depiction of Satan himself, played
by the film's director Benjamin Christensen.
To have this level of rampantly satanic
imagery back in the 1920s was quite the
artistic gamble — but it seems that the risk paid
off. One hundred years later, the film is often
regarded as a stylistic trendsetter, especially
through its distinctive hybrid format. Any
film that uses documentary segments to further a
fictional narrative owes its existence to "Haxan."
"We're seeing 'Nosferatu.'"
"Yeah, I don't know why I'm going, but
I'm just in a weird headspace today."
"Which is exactly how you wanna
see German expressionism."
Certain horror films are more than just
memorable, instead achieving a level of
influence that can last a century — and definitely
longer. This is the case with F. W. Murnau's 1922
picture "Nosferatu," which features one
of the earliest onscreen depictions of a
vampire. A loose adaptation of Bram Stoker's
"Dracula" — with key details changed to avoid
any legal conflict with Stoker's widow
— the handsome vampire was turned into
a wretched ghoul called Count Orlok, played by
Max Schreck. "Nosferatu" follows Thomas Hutter,
who travels to Transylvania to secure the
signature of Count Orlok for a real estate deal.
Soon enough, Hutter's wife finds herself in
Orlok's crosshairs, meaning that Hutter must race
against the clock to save his beloved. "Nosferatu"
is a true chiller in every sense of the word:
from Count Orlok rising from his coffin to
his sinister shadow being cast on the walls,
this film is loaded with unforgettable
imagery. To this day, many critics still
hail "Nosferatu" as a legendary classic of the
horror genre — and it isn't hard to see why.
No list of silent horror classics would be truly
complete without an appearance or two by the man
of a thousand faces, Lon Chaney. Chaney's
now-legendary physical language and facial
expressions originated out of familial necessity,
as both of his birth parents were deaf. His
command of physical performance, along with his
skill with theatrical makeup, helped to propel
him into the limelight. Chaney soon became best
known for his on-screen portrayals of physically
deformed, often misunderstood misfits, like
Quasimodo in "The Hunchback of Notre Dame."
This film, while not the first, stands
as one of the more famous adaptations of
Victor Hugo's famous 1831 novel. For such an
early film production, everything in it feels
grand in scale — especially the sets, which
all perfectly capture the film's setting of
15th century France. But of course, the major
highlight of the film is Chaney as Quasimodo,
who takes advantage of every moment he's on
screen. "The Hunchback of Notre Dame" is still a
silent cinematic classic, and the film that helped
to propel Lon Chaney to silver screen stardom.
Long before the Phantom of the Opera was
belting out melodramatic show tunes on Broadway,
he was terrifying moviegoers in 1925.
In another one of his iconic roles,
Lon Chaney plays the titular Phantom, a
disfigured musical genius who resides in the
decrepit sewers below the Paris Opera House.
He falls madly in love with Christine Daaé,
an understudy turned starlet who he
begins puppeteering from the shadows.
This take on the tale is truly spellbinding, from
its sinister musical arrangements to Chaney's
awe-inspiring performance — equal parts
horrific and heartbreaking. Underneath his
twisted appearance, Chaney conveys a tangible
pain and rage through his horrific makeup and
prosthetics. From start to finish, the film —
much like the Phantom himself — has you under
its gothic spell. Without Rupert Julian's
adaptation of Gaston Leroux's story, many
of the tropes and visuals we associate with "The
Phantom of the Opera" probably wouldn't exist.
Japan has always had an affinity for truly
resonant and out-of-the-box horror — even
going back many decades. Terrifying creations
from the Land of the Rising Sun often reflect
fears and paranoias that apply heavily to
their native cultural influences. No film
made before World War II is a better example
of this than director Teinosuke Kinugasa's
"A Page of Madness." The 1926 movie concerns
a husband who has taken a janitorial job at
a mental institution to remain close to
his institutionalized wife — but as his
employment continues, the lines between
fantasy and reality begin to erode.
With its twisted angles and
haunting imagery involving masks,
"A Page of Madness" will most definitely be
creeping into your nightmares if you watch
it late at night. Kinugasa's masterpiece is
a one-of-a-kind experience that's definitely
worthy of all the praise that's
been heaped on it over the years.
"Oh, you know the 'Faust' story?"
"No."
Dozens of iconic characters
have made deals with the devil,
but none are more influential than Faust.
Directed by F. W. Murnau of "Nosferatu" fame,
this adaptation of the German legend shares the
same expressionist style as its predecessor.
The story of "Faust" concerns a wager between the
demon Mephisto and an Archangel — the demon bets
the angel that he can corrupt even the most
righteous man's soul. They decide on Faust,
a man willing to dabble in infernal
arts in order to help others. Led
to a crossroads by a mystical book, Faust,
Mephisto, and Lucifer come to an agreement.
Faust tries to use his newfound abilities
to aid people, but his satanic affiliations
isolate him further. As time goes
on, his desire for power and glory
corrupts him and the world around him.
Given its use of satanic iconography,
"Faust" is loaded with surreal and
chilling visuals — the most memorable
of which features the devil towering over a
small village as he spreads a deadly plague.